some are finding surviving cove at 19 is
not the end of their battle with the
virus hefty bills piling up for one
valley man after he spent more than a
hundred days recovering the hospital
victoria saha joins us live from the
newsroom with this story victoria
james sweeney has insurance he was also
unconscious for most of his hospital
stay so he had no say in who cared for
him or whether they were in network now
he's facing an out-of-pocket bill of
more than 80-thousand dollars
63-year-old james sweeney was
unconscious from kovid and had to be put
on a ventilator that was in november he
woke up in february when he woke up he
asked about the hospital bill and was
told insurance was covering it then an
actual bill showed up showing a list of
claims denied by insurance he says he
now owes more than 80 thousand dollars
to providers
this week has been really tough i have
slept well any night
i keep waking up in the middle of night
trying to figure out how i'm going to
cover these bills sweeney says his
insurance company told him although the
hospital was a network the doctors who
treated him were not
i reached out to saint rose dominican
siena hospital they said in part dignity
health believes that access to health
care is a basic human right that should
be available and affordable for all
people reporting live from the newsroom
victoria saha 8 news now